[Music]
the mainstream media outdid themselves
this week proving once again that
they're not interested in journalism all
they seem to care about is destroying
Trump D legitimizing his presidency in
going after as we saw with judge Jeanine
anybody that likes the president watch
this can we still call President Trump
the leader of the free world
can we still call him the leader of the
United States it's just as serious to me
as the Cuban Missile Crisis in terms of
an attack or the 9/11 attack his
performance today will live in infamy as
much as the Pearl Harbor attack or
crystal knocked when do we see almost a
shadow government come out and say we
cannot side with the government whether
it's the cabinet or the senator Trump
has been a problem as I say and now I
feel it's it's a crisis of real urgency
and I'm not sure what we can do except
try to contain them in various ways the
definition it meets is the first word of
the impeachment article in the
Constitution which is treason bribery
and high crimes of misdemeanors you had
a one-word reaction to what you saw
yesterday treason treason yeah all right
here with reaction all throw the
brand-new book its out this week
briefing the briefing politics the press
and the president former White House
press secretary Sean Spicer you know
look you live this every day for a while
and I told you at the time I don't know
why you do that job I think Sarah
Sanders I said the same thing to her and
I did see her briefly in Helsinki one
particular case all of the meddling and
interference happened under Obama
uranium one happened under Obama Crimea
Ukraine happened under Obama the cirrie
of red light happened under Obama and
I'm looking at this and I'm like they've
lost all sense of any objectivity what
do you think it is well I think clearly
they have a problem they thought that
Hillary Clinton was going to win the
election they were wrong and now they
will refuse to give President Trump the
credit he deserves in each of the areas
whether it's the economic policy foreign
policy or what have you no matter how
good the President does no matter how he
reshapes the judiciary deregulates the
regulatory state it's never good enough
there's always a problem
I talked about this extensively in the
book how we face that headwind on every
single issue no matter what we did and
it started through it was throughout the
campaign and it started on day one it
was literally the press trying to D
legitimize the president to find a way
to go into that Oval Office and say well
there's something wrong they falsely
accused the president of taking the bust
out of the Oval Office that of Martin
Luther King I mean and that's throughout
my entire book part of the reason that I
wanted to write this book Sean was to
make people understand the headwinds
that we faced every day in terms of this
administration and this president you
know you've had a very interesting life
and background and your family
actually I you grew up in Rhode Island
which surprised me right
well it didn't I think yeah I I didn't
the next town over five years which is
interesting and the thing is and you
served your country and then you go into
battle with this group of people that
just want to destroy you every single
day what do you take out of it how what
do you learn I know what doesn't kill us
makes us stronger or I can give you
every cliche but you still live it well
I think number one you're right it makes
us stronger it makes us better and
better conservatives this for in my case
I think that I have to you have to
refine your argument you have to be
stronger and smarter and constantly
thinking because you're right they come
at you with everything that they have
and the more successful that you may be
may have the more success that you may
have the stronger they're going to come
at you and that's you've seen that time
and time again no matter what we've done
on the conservative side they're going
to come after us in general and this
president I think all every one of the
studies whether it's Harvard pew the
media Research Center every single one
of them the preponderance of coverage is
highly negative the press should go
after politicians and government
officials it should sleep but 90% of the
time doesn't make sense but even at the
expense it's like the Democrats don't
want this president to succeed because
if he does as he's doing that is a a
real clear present danger to their main
goal which is to get power back so every
success makes them more desperate right
you heard you heard Bill Maher who
so many people love to go on his show
and and treat him with you know as if
he's a normal journalist the bottom line
is that he talked about he wants the
economy to tank because that's the only
way you're gonna defeat him think about
what that means to every every today
Americans yeah I mean yeah that means
people lose jobs that need them the
Forgotten men and women the book is
fantastic I'm reading it now loving
every minute of it it's in bookstores
everywhere amazon.com the briefing Sean
Spicer thanks for being with us